♪ ♪ ♪
- Vendredi soir à Montréal,
des clients s'amusent, dansent,
sans aucune distanciation
et sans masque.
♪ ♪ ♪
Un constat que
nous avons fait lors de
la visite de deux endroits bien
connus, le 22 octobre dernier.
FRANÇOIS BOITARD,
copropriétaire, Rouge Bar
- Il y a des restaurants,
ils ont fait rentrer des DJ
et ils font le party aussi,
donc c'est partout à Montréal.
On n'a plus aucun plaisir
à faire notre métier,
c'est-à-dire qu'on doit gérer
les gens qui veulent s'amuser
et on doit gérer la police, qui
est là pour nous réprimander.
- François affirme que la police
peut se présenter jusqu'à 3 fois
lors d'une seule soirée.
Le SPVM confirme que
les interventions sont
nombreuses, sans spécifier
les établissements ciblés.
Empêcher les gens de danser
est devenu presque impossible.
- Maintenant, avec le passeport
vaccinal, je vous dirais que
les gens deviennent agressifs,
parce qu'ils ne comprennent plus
qu'on vienne les embêter.
♪ ♪ ♪
- La goutte qui a fait
déborder le vase : les vidéos
diffusées où des milliers de
personnes chantent et dansent
à l'intérieur du Centre Bell.
- Quand on est gros, on peut
se permettre d'en abuser.
Quand on est petit, une petite
PME, bien, on doit souffrir.
- Est-ce que la police
vient souvent ici?
- Constamment.
- Situation similaire
au club La Voûte; le sentiment
d'injustice est très fort.
NAZIM TEDJINI,
propriétaire, club La Voûte
- Si le gouvernement est assez
à l'aise de laisser ça arriver,
il est temps de nous laisser
ouvrir, à opérer à pleine
capacité, sincèrement,
tant qu'on respecte évidemment
le passeport vaccinal.
- Nazim dénonce également
une autre réalité qui
passe sous le radar :
les soirées illégales privées.
- C'est la nature humaine
de vouloir se regrouper,
donc on blâme pas
les gens de le faire.
Un party illégal, il y aura
pas de "contact tracing".
- Est-ce qu'il y en a
présentement à Montréal?
- Oui.
- Tous les week-ends, il y en a?
- Oui, tout le temps.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Le DJ Adam Ouakrim connaît
bien l'industrie à Montréal.
Il travaille maintenant
en informatique pour payer
son loyer, avec quelques
contrats ici et là.
ADAM OUAKRIM, DJ et
gestionnaire du collectif Fleed
- Je pense pas qu'il faille
pointer du doigt tel ou tel
établissement qui essaie
de faire vivre la musique
et la culture sur Montréal.
Je pense qu'au contraire,
il faudrait pousser
pour que les discothèques
réouvrent correctement.
- Des allégements ont été
annoncés dernièrement :
à partir du 1er novembre,
les établissements pourront
ouvrir jusqu'à 3 heures du matin
et pourront fonctionner au
maximum de leur capacité.
- C'est une espèce de jeu
du chat et de la souris
qui se crée un petit peu
avec les tenanciers, parce
qu'on essaie de contrôler
le monde, mais c'est pas facile.
- On a du mal à les garder
assis... en arrêtant de
vendre de l'alcool à 1 h.
Deux heures de plus,
c'est mission impossible.
Ils sont en train de donner
un outil... à la police pour
faire encore plus de répression.
- Le gouvernement dénonce
les rassemblements illégaux et
rappelle que la responsabilité
de faire appliquer
les mesures sanitaires
revient aux promoteurs
des grands événements.
Québec est en réflexion pour
assouplir les mesures sanitaires
dans les bars et promet
une annonce sous peu.
Entre-temps, les gens
de l'industrie se sentent
impuissants et, surtout,
incompris par les autorités.
Ici Marie-Michelle Lauzon,
Radio-Canada, M